alors c'était comment qu'il s'agisse de
votre récent passage chez le dentiste ou
du dernier concert de votre idole quand
on vous pose cette petite question alors
c'était comment
c'est pour essayer d'avoir votre
ressenti sur l'expérience positive ou
négative que vous avez vécu à quel point
vous en garder un souvenir agréable ou
bien désagréable mais est ce que c'est
la même chose d'avoir apprécié un moment
et d'en garder un bon souvenir
le souvenir des bons ou des mauvais
moments c'est important parce
qu'évidemment c'est tout ce qu'il nous
reste à la fin l'expérience qu'on a vécu
la sensation instantanée qu'on a eu à ce
moment là c'était temporaire alors que
le souvenir lui il demeure dans les
années 90 le psychologue daniel kahneman
s'est intéressé à ce qu'on retenait de
nos expériences positives et négatives
et il a obtenu quelques résultats plutôt
contre intuitif
[Musique]
pour examiner les souvenirs que l'on
garde d'un épisode désagréable
daniel kahneman a travaillé avec un
médecin qui faisait passer des
coloscopies alors je vous passe les
détails mais la coloscopie un examen de
l'intérieur du côlon est pas connue pour
être une des expériences les plus
agréables qui soit à l'époque de l'étude
et c'était au canada on l'a pratiqué
principalement sous anesthésie légère et
kaman a voulu comprendre l'évolution de
la douleur ressentie par ceux qui
subissaient cet examen
alors pour ça il a utilisé 154 vrais
patients qui devait passer une
coloscopie
ceux ci disposaient pendant l'examen
d'un petit boîtier leur permettant de
faire varier sur un écran un curseur
pour indiquer le niveau de douleur qu'il
ressentait et ils avaient pour
instruction de le faire toutes les
minutes
sachant que l'examen pouvait durer en
gros entre cinq minutes et plus d'une
heure grâce à cela kahneman a pu
récupérer pour les 154 patients une
courbe indiquant l'évolution de leur
douleur au cours de l'examen
voici deux exemples de courbes obtenu
pour deux patients différents en
regardant ces deux courbes à votre avis
lequel des deux patients a le plus
souffert au total a tous envie de penser
que c'est le patient b et bien pour le
savoir en plus de cette notation en
temps réel kalman a demandé aux patients
une fois l'examen terminé et qu'ils
étaient revenus dans leur chambre de
noter leurs expériences la question
était sur une échelle de 1 à 10 comment
évaluez vous la quantité totale d'un
confort que vous avez ressenti au cours
de l'examen et il leur a aussi reposer
cette question à nouveau mais un mois
plus tard intuitivement on a envie de
penser que cette quantité totale d'un
confort doit être liée à la fois la
durée et à l'intensité de la douleur et
corresponde plus ou moins à l'air sous
la courbe et que donc par exemple sur
ces deux patients a et b le patient mais
aurait vécu globalement une expérience
plus désagréable que le patient à ce
qu'a constaté kahneman c'est que la note
globale dépend des principalement de
deux choses
l'intensité maximale de la douleur
ressentie au cours de l'examen et le
niveau de douleur à la fin de l'examen
dans les trois dernières minutes
ce que vous voyez ici ce sont les
coefficients de corrélation entre d'un
côté les évaluations globales
juste après l'examen et un mois plus
tard et de l'autre l'intensité maximale
l'intensité finale et la durée de
l'examen pour ceux qui sont pas
familiers avec l'idée
le coefficient de corrélation quand ses
proches de zéro il n'y a pas de
corrélation et plus on se rapproche de 1
plus la corrélation est forte
et ici on voit donc que les notes
globales sont très corrélé à l'intensité
maximale et à l'intensité finale mais
pas à la durée de l'examen
c'est ce que cannes mahnaz appelait la
loi de l'apogée fin ce que les gens
retiennent d'une expérience douloureuse
c'est son intensité à son apogée et son
intensité à la fin mais la durée joue
très peu et c'est quand même perturbant
de penser que le patient b avec cette
courbe de douleur a gardé un mauvais
souvenir de son examen que le patient a
alors qu'il a objectivement en plus
souffert une explication qu'on peut
envisager c'est que les patients ont
probablement du mal à prendre en compte
la durée pour attribuer leurs notes
parce qu'ils s'imaginent pas forcément
que l'examen aurait pu être plus court
sur le plan médical alors qu'ils peuvent
facilement concevoir qu'il aurait pu
être moins douloureux mais à ce sujet
kahneman a fait une autre étude encore
plus perturbante
il a reçu des sujets en leur disant
qu'ils allaient faire trois expériences
première expérience plonger une de leurs
mains dans de l'eau à 14 degrés pendant
60 secondes alors l'expérience est pas
hyper agréable mais c'est supportable
quand même et à l'issue des 60 secondes
on leur ferait une serviette chaude pour
se sécher la main deuxième expérience
plonger leur autre main dans de l'eau à
14 degrés pendant 60 secondes un pareil
puis dents de loup à 15 degrés pendant
30 secondes et à la fin enfin serviette
chaude alors un point de méthodes
important l'ordre de ces deux
expériences étaient tirés au hasard pour
chaque sujet certains faisaient d'abord
la plus longue d'autres la plus courte
les mains aussi été choisis
aléatoirement et puis après avoir fait
ces deux expériences
kahneman leur annoncer que la troisième
expérience serait de refaire l'une des
deux précédentes mais celle de leur
choix alors en principe entre 60
secondes à 14 degrés et 60 secondes à 14
degrés puis 30 secondes à 15 degrés y'a
pas photo 1
la première provoc objectivement moins
de désagréments donc 100 % des gens
auraient dû choisir de répéter celle ci
est pourtant 70% des gens ont préféré
répéter la deuxième expérience la plus
longue
on retrouve ce qu'on a vu avec la
coloscopie
il semble que la durée ne rentre pas
tellement ligne de compte mais que le
fait que l'expérience se termine plus
progressivement aide à atténuer le
souvenir douloureux même si la quantité
totale de douleur est objectivement plus
importante et on peut avoir ce type de
résultats pas seulement avec des
événements désagréables mais aussi les
evènement agréable pour faire la
comparaison des chercheurs ont réalisé
le même genre d'expérience que la
coloscopie
mais avec des gens regardant des
séquences vidéo les sujets devaient
noter en temps réel leur niveau de
plaisir ou de déplaisir alors qu'ils
regardaient des petits films soient
particulièrement agréable des animaux
qui joue par exemple soit
particulièrement désagréable genre d
amputation il existait plusieurs types
de films dans chaque catégorie et chaque
film existait en deux durées différentes
et comme pour la coloscopie en plus de
l'évaluation en temps réel les sujets
ont dû noter à la fin leur expérience
globale et en regardant à nouveau les
corrélations il a été montré que c'était
l'intensité maximale et l'intensité
finale qui était le plus liée à la note
globale tandis que la durée ne jouait
aucun rôle en particulier pour les films
agréable les effets du même genre ont
également été montré pour ce qu'on
retient d'un bon repas la fin est
particulièrement importante bien nos
vacances pour lesquels la durée ne
compte pas tant que ça autre exemple
intéressant surtout pour ceux qui ont un
business
des chercheurs ont montré qu'on gardait
un meilleur souvenir d'une files
d'attentes qui commence lentement puis
s'accélère que l' inverse
même si la durée totale a été plus
importante ce qui se passe à la fin
compte plus que la durée
si on élargit un peu on se dit que ça
peut aussi s'appliquer à des oeuvres
d'art l'important est de soigner
l'apogée et la fin alors je donne deux
exemples qui ne respectent pas cette
règle est que je trouve assez
intéressant pour ceux qui ont lu le
seigneur des anneaux ça se termine
évidemment par une grande bataille
épique mais qui n'est pas la dernière du
livre il reste après un chapitre un peu
bizarre où les hobbits retour ne
libérait la comté et qui m'a donné un
espèce de sentiment étrange parce que le
combat a l'air complètement ridicule à
côté de ce qu'on vient de vivre avant au
lieu de se terminer en apothéose sur
l'affrontement du gros boss de fin eh
ben on termine sur une espèce de sous
bataille dont on se demande ce qu'elle
fait là d'ailleurs je crois que peter
jackson a viré ce passage dans le film
autre exemple plus récent la la land
le film commence par une scène
absolument incroyable à la fin de
laquelle je suis resté scotché sur mon
siège
le problème c'est qu'à aucun moment à
mon avis le film n'a retrouvé cette
intensité qu'il ya dans la scène
d'ouverture
en gros le réalisateur a lâché tous les
chevaux dans les trois premières minutes
et je m'attendais à retrouver ça au
milieu ou à la fin
et ben non et du coup le film m'a laissé
une espèce d'impression de moyens bof
il ya plein d'autres cas un penser à ces
séries qui n'arrive pas à finir et du
coup même si vous avez apprécié la
première saison eh bien vous en garder
un souvenir moyens on pourrait faire le
même genre de raisonnement avec les
mariages qui se termine en divorce à
mais bon comme je suis pas plus ce
conseiller matrimonial que critique de
film on va revenir à la science un truc
récurrents qu'on a vu c'est que la durée
de l'expérience semble ne pas compter
dans notre évaluation rétrospective
comme si on n'avait pas de difficulté à
juger la qualité mais qu'on était assez
mauvais pour mesurer les quantités les
durées dans son livre pingping fast and
slow kahneman explique ça en disant que
dans plein de situations où il faut
décider de quelque chose eh bien notre
cerveau ne fait pas une analyse
rationnelle complète 1 mais fonctionne
avec ce qu'on appelle des heuristiques
c'est à dire des raccourcis permettant
d'avoir rapidement une réponse sans trop
se planter et manifestement noz ristic
prennent plus facilement en compte la
qualité que la quantité et il ya une
expérience amusante qu'il illustre bien
des chercheurs ont demandé à des
participants d'évaluer la valeur à leurs
yeux d'un service de vaisselle
c'est à dire combien ils seraient prêts
à payer pour l'acheter un premier
service comportait 24 pièces il y avait
huit grandes assiettes 8 ball et huit
petites assiettes à dessert et un second
service était totalement identique mais
avec en plus huit as et 8 soucoupe
sauf que deux des tasses et 7 des
soucoupes été ébréchée quand on leur
présentait les deux ensemble les
participants attribué au second service
une valeur supérieure au premier ce qui
est assez rationnel puisqu'il contient
exactement la même chose avec des trucs
en plus mais quand on leur présentait
séparément les deux c'était au premier
service qu'ils attribuaient en moyenne
une valeur supérieure
il jugeait ou prenez plus facilement en
compte la qualité que la quantité
toutes ces questions de souvenirs que
l'on garde dunfield à temps pour nos
vacances peuvent vous sembler assez
anecdotique mais si on vient à l'exemple
de l'examen médical
eh bien on voit que ça pose quand même
quelques problèmes souvenez-vous des
courbes de douleur des patients a et b
ci de façon contre intuitive le patient
b a conservé un mais
souvenir de son examen que le patient a
est ce qu'on devrait pas prolonger
artificiellement l'examen du patient à
c'est facile il suffirait de rester
quelques minutes de plus en essayant de
lui faire un peu mal mais pas trop et à
la fin c'est assez paradoxal parce que
ça veut dire lui infliger
artificiellement une souffrance
supplémentaire n'ayant aucune
justification médicale
juste pour qu'il garde un bon souvenir
de son examen
kalman a d'ailleurs proposé cette
expérience à des médecins réalisant des
coloscopies et effectivement ce dont on
avait artificiellement prolonger
l'examen de trois minutes conserver un
meilleur souvenir tout ça pose quand
même quelques problèmes d'éthique
est ce qu'un médecin peut infliger de la
souffrance inutile avec comme seule
motivation de laisser un meilleur
souvenir aux patients ces graines très
discutable comme disait hippocrate
primum no quéré premièrement ne pas
nuire et donc on pourrait trancher le
débat en disant que l'important c'est la
santé du patient etp à son bon souvenir
donc non sauf que ça devient plus
compliqué si on prend en compte que le
souvenir plus ou moins douloureux d'un
examen va jouer un rôle sur le fait que
le patient reviennent faire cet examen
plus tard dans le cas des coloscopies
que certains patients doivent faire à
intervalles réguliers un pur du
dépistage c'est évidemment important
qu'ils aient envie de revenir
et donc on peut se demander si un
médecin a le droit d'infliger un peu de
souffrance inutile en fin d'examen au
nom de la santé future de son patient eh
bien je pense que c'est une question
d'éthique qui est compliqué et ça me
semble suffisamment intense pour
conclure cette vidéo en beauté merci
d'avoir suivi la vidéo si elle vous a
plu n'hésitez pas à la partager sur toi
ceux qui connaissent pas déjà la chaîne
vous pouvez vous abonner la cloche les
accus la chaîne facebook twitter vous
pouvez vous dire sur syfy et je vous dis
à très bientôt pour des devis
[Musique]